the eve of the g20 summit the Russian
president spoke at length to the UK's
Financial Times on key threats to global
security
we had no common ground on many issues
that are key for us for the US and for
the whole world for example the issue of
the u.s. unilateral withdrawal from the
anti-ballistic missile treaty that we
have always considered as the touchstone
of the whole international security we
had long discussions and disputes on
this issue we had offered different
solutions from my side I had undertaken
rather energetic efforts to convince our
American partners not to withdraw from
the treaty or to withdraw from it but
ensuring international security for a
long period I suggested working jointly
on missile defense projects that should
have involved the US Russia and Europe
they stipulated specific parameters of
this cooperation I am convinced that the
world would be a different place today
had our American partners accepted this
proposal unfortunately this did not
happen we can see that the situation is
developing in another direction new
weapons and cutting-edge military
technology are coming to the fore well
this is not our choice but today we
should at least do everything so as not
to aggravate the situation
all this fuss about spies and counter
spies none of it is worth serious
intergovernmental relations the spy
story is not worth five kopecks
or five pounds for that matter issues
concerning intergovernmental relations
are measured in billions and the fate of
millions of people how can we compare
one with the other
you